key avez vous connu par les bouquets
des rencontres deux cent cinquante mille
kilomètres au compteur une soixantaine
de pays visités c'est la vie que mènent
florence renault depuis maintenant sept
ans il fait super chaud donc là je vais
faire mes papiers pas rentrer en namibie
reporter d'image pour france 3 cette
orléanaise de naissance a tout quitté
pour se lancer dans un tour du monde
elle le raconte sur un blog et partage
son quotidien sur les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
pas d'itinéraire précis ni prévue de
longue date mais une seule ligne de
conduite voyager uniquement stop
un itinéraire pouces que les par la
crise du coc vie de 19 en mars dernier
florence se retrouve bloqué plusieurs
mois au cameroun pour cause de fermeture
de frontières le retour en france
attendra
une fois en france florence envisage
d'écrire un livre et pourquoi pas de
réaliser un film de ses 7 ans
d'itinérance
quel périple et quel plaisir de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau florence
renault welcome back bienvenue à nouveau
en france et ici à france 3 centre val
de loire où vous avez travaillé avant de
partir on sait même pas par où commencer
tellement il doit y avoir à dire d'un
tel voyage
racontez-nous d'abord si vous vous en
souvenez peut-être comment vous est
venue cette idée cette envie de voyage
en 2013 et aussi pourquoi l'avoir fait
en stop alors en fait c'est un très
vieux projet depuis que je suis ado je
rêvais de faire le tour du monde comme
beaucoup de gens je pense est en fait
j'ai toujours repoussée à plus tard à
plus tard à plus tard et là j'étais
arrivé à 27 ans et j'avais fini mes
études et j'avais déjà travaillé j'ai
mis d'argent de côté donc j'avais plus d
excuses et je me suis dit bon si je ne
fais pas avant mes 30 ans je le ferai
jamais donc il faut que je fasse
maintenant quoi donc voilà il ya en fait
j'avais l'habitude de faire du stop et
dont nous dit ben vas-y je le faire en
stop comme ça ça me couper les coûts et
en plus ça me permettra de rencontrer
plein de monde dans tous les pays donc
voilà un voyage qui devait durer deux
ans au départ finalement c'est 8 qu'est
ce qui s'est passé comment comment
expliquer ces six ans supplémentaires
alors au tout début de mon voyage donc
en fait j'ai commencé de dans les
hanches et fait du stop jusqu'à la
vendée là j'ai traversé en voilier stop
et j'ai voyagé en brésil et là au brésil
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait la
notion des distances étaient vraiment
faussé que en fait
tout était vraiment loin que les routes
étaient défoncés que les voitures
étaient défoncés que ça allait mettre au
moins de 3 ans à cette vitesse ça et
puis de là en fait j'ai rajouté une
année
comment on fait pour traverser un océan
en stop aux justes vont nous expliquer
un peu dur alors du coup j'ai fait du
bateau stop et quelquefois j'ai même
fait de l'avion stop en fait la plupart
du temps pour les bateaux je suis allé
dans les ports de plaisance à l'ancienne
en fait à discuter avec les marins sur
les pontons voir si quelqu'un partait
dans ma direction est est ce que vous
avez eu des moments où vous avez eu peur
tout de même dans ce voyage est ce que
vous vous êtes fait peur simplement du
fait du voyage ou même peut-être parfois
en tant que femme se retrouver dans des
situations pas toujours confortable ça
vous est arrivé ouais plein de fois
alors comment vous avez réagi dans ce
genre de sites
alors quand c'est quand j'ai peur quand
j'ai des situations désagréables avec
des gens en fait j'ai un peu mais
réparti tout fait parce que c'est arrivé
tellement de fois malheureusement que je
sais déjà comment retourner la situation
pour pour m'en sortir et après il ya des
moments j'ai eu peur c'était plus dans
la nature
où j'ai pris des risques en fait
enfin sans m'en rendre compte c'était
pas volontaire mais d'être voilà en face
d'un ours d'un hippopotame me retrouver
sur des avis et sans crampons de
traverser une rivière avec trop de
courants enfin voilà oui d'accord
d'éducation effectivement on se fait
peur dans ces cas là je reviens à la
crise sanitaire ou est ce que vous étiez
en mars 2020 quand le monde entier se
confinait alors le jour où
le cameroun a fermé ses frontières en
fait c'est le jour où je suis rentré
chez l'entré deux heures avant qu'ils
ferment leurs frontières et je me suis
retrouvé bloqué aucun monde pendant huit
mois
de là finalement je suis passé alors moi
j'ai refusé de me faire rapatrier parce
que ça fait déjà sept ans que j'étais
sur la route était hors de question pour
moi de d'abandonner mon projet même si
tout le monde mais c'est bon c'est bon
la rampe non non je tient jusqu'au bout
et donc huit mois au cameroun de là je
suis passé au nigeria pendant trois mois
et la bloquer à nouveau et là en fait
j'ai trouvé un avion stop pour aller
jusqu'au maroc donc je me suis dit super
du maroc serait plus très loin et là
j'arrive au maroc et quelques semaines
après boom le maroc ferme à nouveau ses
frontières et là j'ai été bloqué cinq
mois au maroc est donc là au mois de
juillet le mois dernier en fait j'ai
trouvé un voilier stop pour m'emmener du
maroc vers l'espagne et revenir en
france et on est très contents de vous
avoir merci beaucoup florence renault
d'être passé sur ce plateau alors je
précise que vous avez des projets pour
l'avenir on le suivra tout ça de près on
a entendu dans le sujet peut-être un
film on va suivre tout ça de très près
soyez en sûr merci beaucoup d'être
passés par notre plateau ce soir